yeah it turns out all you women just
hate each other and we don't listen to
you or take your advice seriously have
you seen the we're going to get this to
the next but have you seen the daily
wire [__] that keeps like trying to
destroy oh the plane girl yeah yeah I
went out the plain girl's annoying don't
get me wrong but we'll play that in a
second but like she's trying to get her
like arrested and I'm like what is wrong
with you yeah she was literally like uh
so we're not filing federal plane
hijacking charges and this is a daily
wire chick and then she goes if it was a
man this would have been different I go
how is this any different than black
lives matter people saying a black guy
would have been killed by the cops like
you're doing the same thing you [__]
retards but anyway and honestly uh
you're right
um a guy would be more likely to be
arrested in that situation however if a
dude was having an obvious mental health
situation which is what that appeared to
be uh there is a difference between
freaking out not having a grip on
reality and saying oh my God I'm under
the impression this plane's gonna blow
up versus I've planted a bomb on this
plane yeah you know what I mean right
that is that is and that's what she's
trying to do she's trying to get like
like the whole point is if I call an
airline right now and go oh yeah the
1150 to such and such there's a [__]
bomb yeah no I'm going to prison like
that's without question but if you're
like I think the pie attacks bud and
they let you out the door it's like okay
that guy's crazy
um so yeah she came okay so by the way
not as pretty dolled up you know what
that was my first impression looks
better without makeup on she was
prettier it just with the hair up on the
plane looks you want to know she'll you
know I gotta returns look at the eyes
she over did the the makeup in the eye
she over to the face
um guys I think you're just blinded by
the fact that she was a woman schizo
posting in real life and that was the
hottest well no yes yeah yeah you're
right but you know the other thing is is
like
now you have all the [__] retards
going like it's clearly not the same
person this is clearly not it is clearly
the same person she's wearing makeup
like
everything is fake and gay yeah okay I
mean we've all seen the two we've all
seen those uh time lapse videos where
they show how ugly people can suddenly
look I mean there's a reason why some
can fool somebody in just a photograph
of their face and it's because it's 80
clown makeup and contouring and hair
extensions and you go oh yeah I guess so
I want you to smear all that [__] off
you go oh gee God Almighty okay yeah
okay like an hour ago okay cool was it a
Blair white ugly or Laura lumor no but
I'm just saying like they're like an
hour ago like if you see a picture of a
[__] off whole full body picture okay
but I'm just saying here you see
photographs of even ugly chicks and you
go damn she fine and then they take the
makeup off and you're like wow that was
all [__] just a thousand dollar
makeup job so so this is her video this
is her thing hi everyone it's me
Tiffany Gomez probably hey you already
known as the crazy Tiffany Gomez she
looks sounds and has the name of a porn
star that's on the fifth page of [__]
xHamster
sounds specific now if you're in
Louisiana you have to put your ID in to
look at that it's so specific I'm glad
you got the call back it's completely
warranted
as you know I have been unwilling to
speak on the viral video but I do then
why did you make your account a month
ago and why did you put a tweet out
saying about that video
why are you only following 16 people did
you see who she's following no
oh no oh no oh no oh no she's only
following 16 people here hold on let me
put let me pull it up for you here
because I have to go to her page
uh Tiffany Gomez
following 16 people
hear you go okay ready uh I've already
seen branding Los Angeles literally
three ngos already I see in the talk
okay project stop bullying.gov Timmy
pool
Matt taibi Lex Friedman oh doctor
Jordan's twins Joe Rogan Barstool wait
wait wait oh my God wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait to be fair to
be fair to be fair that looks like she
clicked some things when she joined and
said just follow these people no no no
no no that looks like Marsh
looks like a talent agency contacted her
this is all shows that she's going to be
on look at the shows so she's gonna be a
set right of Center grifter yeah yep
yeah thanks guys remember how we didn't
want you to find ntmz we all said that
would ruin it and you ruined it thanks
thanks to thank that daily wire [__]
for like exactly what the [__] I told
you guys was going to happen why did we
have to ruin the Mystique
it was cool yeah and every time we get
to know people they disappoint us yep we
used to have a schizo posting MILF and
now we have a [__] who got famous for
being a [__] and she's gonna be on all
these [__] shows and they're all gonna
have their they're gonna have their
conversations about conversations
it never stops it never stops and I
don't want to be around anymore okay so
okay
shifter and chat just goes open mouth
soy point
yeah okay okay so uh Tiffany what what
happened when you're on that plane
um I can't wait to watch that interview
Sunday conversation with a [__] who's
famous for screaming in the plane
first and foremost yeah
time to cash in want to I mean why did
you rent an Airbnb for this video still
would though right no furniture oh yeah
of course
take full it gives me Trish Stratus
vibes when she's got the makeup and
stuff you guys ready for my actions they
were completely unacceptable no but what
[__] did you see on the plane
see this this video she gives no answers
to what happened
distress or not
I should have been
in trouble of my emotions you're a woman
that's literally nobody's expecting that
of you yeah yeah especially like
especially attractive white women like
nobody in any trust me I I nobody at any
point said wow she's acting like not
atypical of a white woman yeah man ma'am
you're a white woman in America
controlling your emotions as your older
brother's job yeah exactly right or a
father figure at least or I don't know a
husband a husband well
that was not the case listen the only
thing that makes you not a typical white
woman is that you got a plane to have to
de-board and for some reason you had
enough Charisma that we didn't want to
Cave your [__] Scotland with a tire
iron like we do to every other person we
see in those videos because you are hot
and you got nice tits being white helped
and then we over thought the whole
[__] thing we tracked her down and
now Lex Friedman's got no I'm done with
you people I'm done I'm done
my use of profanity was completely you
know what I take it back that chick from
The Daily wire is right let's get this
[__] thrown in [__] prison gimbo but
also the daily wire trick should also be
thrown in prison yeah but all but one of
those like you know lesbian prisons like
in the pornos but like a big brother one
where they have the cameras and we get
like to watch them and we turn daily
wire into a prison the daily wire is a
prison
you think anybody wants to be there
and I want to apologize to everyone on
that plane especially those that had
children aboard I don't know Matt Walsh
is probably just happy to have a home
and trying to explain to your kid what
in the world Matt Walsh is happy to not
be making videos in his minivan anymore
we all have our bad moments
yeah this is your bad moment far worse
than others and mine happened to be
caught on camera for the whole world to
see no but is that a bad moment
you're right I've had bad moments
Mercer's had bad moments but Mercer's
never said that plane's gonna blow up
like we've never
look she's comparing like getting drunk
and yelling at your friend or fist
fighting your boy like that that'll
happen that happens for guys like well
you have a bad moment and you guys get
drunk and [__] blow up and then
you're cool whatever but with her it's
not that with her it's like the plane is
gonna go down everyone's gonna die
you're like
um yeah you're seeing [__] you know
ghost people and [__] exactly you know
what I mean look I've been on dry have
been on airplanes on every variety of
drugs and alcohol and things you could
think of that you could name
never never had a meltdown on a plane
I had a blow up on a guy one time but it
was like a quick
we were disagreeing over a seat
and it got a little pissy but it was
over very cold
it was a mixture
I was a little coked I was on a lot of
cocaine and I was drunk no no no no no
so this guy come over okay and it was a
British guy he goes um excuse me but
that's my seat and it was like I was you
know whatever and I went oh that's no
problem and I got up and I let him in
his seat but then he just kept like I
don't know nagging me like he was like
lecturing me on why I was sitting in a
seat in the first place and I'd already
gotten up and moved okay fair enough and
it was like it was I didn't get why he
just kept going but I understand if your
ticket says that that's your seat why
would you sit and it got to that point
where I was like would you shut up it
was just like a quick like shut the [__]
up
I'm like everything's fine everything's
cool so that's the closest it ever got
but that was because the guy was acting
like a chick only chicks do that like
when you've already when we've already
agreed to disagree or we've agreed to
agree and I go you know what you're
right I'm wrong I'll I'll make up for
that bump up and then you just still
want to litigate it's like it's over now
if you're ready for another hour and a
half yeah it's like it's like after you
apologize to the woman
and then she keeps bringing it up and
you're like yeah we're done we're good
we I said it won't happen again that's
chip literally that's how men handle it
right hey you know what my bad won't
happen again cool we're good that's it
apology accepted but I need you to hear
me out for a minute
[Laughter]
don't forget that or or how about the
remember like four days ago and you're
like
I thought you said I thought you said
that was over like what four days ago
okay I guess
you remember four days ago we were just
watching Kitchen Nightmares yeah I know
uh yeah yeah and I know I told you it
was scampi and you didn't believe me I
remember and people wonder how kids end
up in oil tanks I don't wonder
um
ma'am you're prettier if you're not as
dolled up it's really annoying me sorry
I can't believe I'm gonna say this but
smile less yes you can't believe I'm
doing the opposite
isn't this whole I'm starting to not
believe this whole thing right because
she's a marketing person
oh no you think she started to think you
know what you know what else Marsh
she wasn't escorted off the plane she
left on her own accord there was nobody
dragging her out turns out the
[__] that wasn't real
was this her all along yes
but don't say that because there's so
many [__] people's theme there's so
many there's so many people that are
doing the whole like this is clearly not
real this isn't real this is a different
person they got rid of her guys none of
us actually thought that she really saw
a ghost on the plane that was jokes we
were like [__] around going like we
were having fun with it we were having
fun the guy that made that painting
where it's like Santa Claus and the
lizard and the the unicorn and the
leprechaun that's brilliant that came
out of it yeah which is fine we were all
joking and like we were all playing
along with the bit but some of you
really thought that the government's
hiding her because she saw somebody on
the plane yeah come on guys the whole
point was that she was schizo posting
and then like you know had nice tits
people really over thought this yes and
and really tried to make something
profound out of it she was a hot chick
with nice tits who had a cute little
yeah [__] right there she does
look we were like okay she's schizo
posting I like her let's hear her out
like we were just having fun again she'd
been an ugly chick we would have moved
on the next day we probably would have
been like throw her in prison for
disrupting people covered the [__]
store no somebody says Big Time
marketing play for her upcoming only
fans from what I've heard she doesn't
need only fans no she's got money she
won't need only fans she's she's now
more famous than only fans hoes she she
can make money without only fans because
there's plenty of Sims that'll pay for
not even seeing titties clip this and
replay it in two years
wire show or something on the blaze
you you think it's going to be right
wing I mean we don't know if she's
right-wing or left wing she hasn't
really said look who she's following
well she's also following CBS that's the
Morning America I think she's just
following Lex Friedman though and Tim
pool and General Peterson and Jordan and
Jordan Peterson yeah even if she just
grabbed these ones or they're just the
people who show she's gonna go on she's
gonna go on two of these shows and be
blacklisted by everybody on the left
yeah they're they're regardless she's
going to end up on the right and then
she'll that's who she's going to grift
from and I think this is all by Design
they realized they realized at some
point that like just trying to stomp out
all the right wing talk and like
de-platform at all it's never gonna work
people are always going to find a
workaround to make money and Keep Their
audience and they realize now
that the only way they can do this is if
they start rolling out they're accepted
[__] you know their pre-accepted
dissident voices right like we can't
have Alex Jones out here but we could
give we'll give you a Sam Tripoli in
russial brand huh you want Sam Tripoli
and Russell Brand no hey Royce what's
the rule what's the rule
well the rule about with hot friends I
mean you there's we have a lot of rules
can't have Nick Fuentes but we'll give
you a TIm pool everything's fake until
proven gay everything's fake until
proven gay that's 100 and now she's been
proven gay I wish she was gay
yeah that would be awesome right hear me
out you get that picture you get that
fake airplane set that they usually if
you saw that video that everyone fell
for and I was immediate I was like yeah
it's a support beam plants don't have
support beams and if people are fighting
with me going like no this looks real
and then I got community checked and I
was like yeah this is a comedy Trope and
we use that set
film a porn with her I mean I'm telling
you I like it yeah that motherfucker's
not real and she [__] a ghost on the
plane I mean people you're saying would
be cool if she was gay she looks like
she's caught some fingers
let's go
go for everyone
um and I have highly enjoyed so many of
the means
on the flip side it is very invasive and
unkind but then why did you enjoy it I
don't know what I would do without the
love and support of my friends and
family
somebody did bring something up uh she
nuked all her account this account see a
single but like for somebody for someone
who's a a big real estate person it is
kind of funny that she already didn't
have a Twitter account like she had well
no yeah they did that's that was
remember because when she got identified
the first time I didn't jump on it
because
there was there were some Rumblings that
like wait a minute some of these
accounts are like not old or you know
they don't have a lot of like old
archive stuff on her it was like all the
stuff that was made recently so I don't
know man this all stinks to me
they are loyal to a fault and I don't
know what I did to deserve them
you're hot yeah I mean ma'am I can
answer these questions for you being hot
helps being hot helps so much in life I
wouldn't know but I mean other people
that are hot tell me being hot helps a
lot in life
[__] women know that women [__]
know that yeah they do let's all [__]
make out with each other boys the ice
these [__] out get in the pile get in
the [__] Park
no but you're not answering the question
and the reason she's not answering the
question is she's not going to give away
why she did it because she wants to get
on shows first of course you have to
give the exclusive right now they're
putting Chum in the water to see which
shows bite we're waiting on the book
deal too
won't have her on I don't think Rogan
will have her on
um but I think Friedman Friedman will
have her on Temple Run
I think Tim's gonna be first
you think because yeah because Tim will
have her on with somebody else too at
the same time you know what I mean so
that's not just her if I was to see if
Tim's not funny but if I was Tim
I would sit there and leave a seat empty
and talk to like you talking to a person
the entire time to make her think
someone said that would be a great thing
that would be good like that's the bit
you do right doesn't he already have
that that Ian guy oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that guy Luke isn't he basically an
empty chair he's the carbon copy of the
other guy Crigler crinking yeah I don't
know Krieger yeah Luke is his buddy he
made at occupy you know that big super
duper rally that got completely and
utterly co-opted by like day two
it lasted three wishes
not that I can use this experience
do a little
bit don't do good yeah do me a favor
don't do any good in the world it's
you're already getting ideas and that's
that's the beginning of when it gets bad
and Rumble signed a deal with her I'm
just kidding I'm kidding that's it
probably that's a joke probably [__]
flyer out by helicopter to UFC but we
got a fish lunch
we got three fish well two fish lunches
we paid for one of them one of the
biggest problems I think that the
internet created we gotta fish lunch was
was making everybody think that they had
to like do something
it's like just you know how you could do
good look at us we don't do anything
yeah raise your [__] kids yeah you
know kids race kids be a good parent
throw a couple bucks to Toys for Tots at
Christmas time feed your local Strays
yeah you know what what else are you
gonna do in the world it's not much you
can do I like you know how you know what
it is make a bee uh um uh create a
beehive somewhere you did you good for
the world there you go you're welcome I
want to do a cardi B Hive there you go
oh God could you imagine how noisy that
would be
like 30 000 bees that all sound like
cardi B that would be so annoying
oh [__] you'd never sleep I don't think
she does